hey 42 here looking your best sometimes
takes a bit of effort whether it's a few
hours shopping for jeans that don't make
your legs look like - toothpick sticking
out of a watermelon we're getting every
single hair in the right place I know
your hair can be cruel sometimes but
putting blood sweat and tears into our
appearance sometimes very literally it's
not a new thing
mankind has been doing it for thousands
and thousands of years apes were barely
out of the trees before they started
wondering if they'd look better with
banana skins over their nipples and a
few crocodile teeth through their
earlobes so today we look at some of the
most extreme modifications that people
have made to their own bodies in ski
lows famous love poem from 1995 he wrote
I wish I was a little bit taller I wish
I was a baller I wish I had a girl who
looked good I would call her and while
the last two are very possible through
practice and tinder your height is
something you're stuck with as it's down
to your skeleton stuff like boobs noses
eyelids are changeable your skeleton is
set though isn't it well not as much as
you think and if you get to work on it
early enough you can put in some serious
interior design changes binding involves
wrapping bandages or cords very tightly
around body parts for many months and
slowly changing the shape and alignment
of your bones it's normally done on
infants as they're much more malleable
the most extreme form is cranial
deformation or head binding which has
occurred all over the world and still
done occasionally in places like
Polynesia and Congo at birth the skull
is made up of 44 separate bone elements
which are connected with tissues called
fontanelles that allow the rapid brain
expansion that occurs at a young age
over time many of these 44 parts fuse
together but surprisingly the skull
never actually stops growing your cheek
bones continuously draw back and your
forehead keeps pushing forward that's
right you're getting a flat face but
before the fusing occurs
you can bind up the skull and elongate
it over a period of months in many
cultures such as the people of taman
island the practice is often done since
a long head is associated with wisdom
for the mains it was fought to be
aesthetically pleasing it's also for
that some cultures were trying to
emulate other tribes who naturally had
this longer head since a mummified
female body found in peru contained a
fetus with an elongated skull meaning it
must have been genetic rather than
caused artificially in china the
practice of foot binding lasted almost a
thousand years where young girls feet
were wrapped to make them as small as
possible it was fought to make them more
attractive and it saved them a fortune
since they could buy their converse from
the kids section similar to binding is
the practice of using rings the most
famous of course are neck rings but it
is a common misconception that you are
actually stretching the neck somehow
lengthening the vertebrae in fact the
weight of the Rings acts to push down
the collarbone and the upper ribs to
give the illusion of a longer giraffe
like neck but it is actually just
shortening your body the practice still
happened today in some areas of Thailand
Myanmar and parts of Africa the Rings
can end up weighing as much as 10 kilos
each and either start at around two
years old since it's less painful to do
it slowly over time or at the age of 12
when they are considered ready to marry
I think they've just been listening to
too much Beyonce guys you don't have to
put a ring on but it's not exactly sure
how the practice started obviously it's
seen as elegant and beautiful but some
people also theorized that it was
protection against tiger attacks it's
the same reason that all British people
wear ankle bracelets in case we were
attacked by budget or is that just me as
for the human bite well it's pretty
pathetic compared to many of our animal
brethren although there are a surprising
amount of human bite attacks over a
thousand per year in New York alone and
if you want to add a bit more bite to
your bite then it's time for some
extreme dentistry teeth sharpening occur
in many pockets all over the world from
the Congolese to parts of Vietnam and
South America it's often an aesthetic
practice to move a chisel
but timbale teeth are for to represent
negative emotions such as anger and
jealousy and so they are filed down to
lessen these emotions for the millions
it was a class-based system so a fancy
set of sharp fangs was the modern-day
equivalent of some red trousers and a
glass of pimps holes we all have them
and they are a source of never-ending
hilarity and embarrassment most mammals
have the same selection of orifices as
we do except from a few types of mole
which have a thing called a cloaca which
is one orifice that has the combined use
of excretion urine and reproduction now
that's just disgusting the cloaca is
standard for all amphibians birds and
reptiles some mollusks have a thing
called a siphon which lets water or
occasionally air flow through it used
for a combination of movement feeding
breathing and reproduction I just hope
they clean it out between each one but
humans have a habit of creating
artificial holes which they fill in with
piercings or gradually expand using a
series of rings the ancient Egyptian
King Tutankhamun is one of the earliest
recorded examples of ear stretching
since you can see it depicted on his
sarcophagus the five thousand-year-old
Otzi the Iceman who was discovered in
the Himalayas also had flesh tunnels
here's my Chemical Romance t-shirt had
unfortunately not survived them in some
Hindu culture a woman's nose was pierced
as a sign that she was ready to be
married it was typically the left
nostril - as that was fought to relieve
some of the pain of childbirth in
ancient times it would also help her to
attach more jewellery to her face which
was important since anything worn for
the wedding was hers to keep whilst
everything else became her husband's so
a chain between her nose and her ear
would have been very handy for hanging
her diamonds
car keys and the remote control
a quick mention - for the lip plate
popular in East Africa in parts of the
Amazon basin which normally involves a
piercing at the upper lip or lower lip
and then a wooden disc inserted to
stretch it out actually I could do with
one of those at Christmas would make
shovelling the food in my face so much
easier and finally from dolphins on your
ankles to this Westerner is an idiot
written in Japanese it's the wonderful
world of tattooing various forms of
tattooing have existed since Neolithic
times perhaps even further back but we
don't have direct evidence of it
Otzi the Iceman who we mentioned before
had tattoo markings to go along with his
pierced ears and his skin is the oldest
example of it we have found so far there
are a wide ranges of reasons and designs
for tattoos from the detailed full-body
tribal images to markings on the arms
and face to indicate a slave or perhaps
a criminal in Europe tattooing was less
common from the middle of the second
millennium but it was reintroduced by
Captain Cook and his crew after a trip
to Tahiti the word tattoo itself comes
from the tur Heaton tatau and many of
cooks crew came back with tattoos which
soon started a trend on the high seas
and made them associated with sailors
and subsequently the criminal classes
they still do have a negative criminal
association in places like Japan and are
strongly discouraged by many parts of
the Islamic world but around 45 million
Americans have one or more tattoos and
1/3 of all British people so if you are
thinking of getting one to train Rebell
then you would actually be better just
getting a side parting putting on a
sensible jumper and smoking a pipe the
rich history of body modifications has
given us some weird and wonderful
traditions and let's hope that some of
them keep going so the entire planet
doesn't end up looking exactly the same
if you're thinking about starting your
own cultural tradition
go ahead but please call your mum before
you stick that thing through there I'm
not sure it's the best idea you've ever
had
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2 do you worry about a zombie
uprising well fear not the US Department
of Defense has you covered the Pentagon
has created a comprehensive plan D
tailing how to counter a zombie
apocolypse you've heard a snake charming
you may have even hypnotized a chicken
but I bet you've never heard of worm
charming